a lot of times as women we we we count
favors and I always say whenever you
have a girl that says we both need to
invest in the into the relationship I
just did so much for him I would argue
that is actually the biggest red flag
because you were keeping score and
keeping score does not work in
relationships because true femininity is
actually selflessness it has nothing to
do with nails it has nothing to do with
fashion it has nothing to do with any of
that it's actually submitting and
serving the men in your life and that's
where a lot of these femininity coaches
get it wrong they focus on looking
feminine instead of being feminine and
the problem is you have a lot of wives
and mothers that might look the part but
they are not the part and it's really a
phenomenon in society which I call the
pretend wives